- Dude, there's no difference between
six figures and eight figures.
Like, what's the fuckin' difference?
- Yeah.
- Like I get, I'm like practical,
I understand, but like what?
Two extra bedrooms?
(rock music)
(light pop music)
What's up, vlog?
Good day.
A little gloomy here.
About to have a great meeting with Kaylen.
Kaylen, five years?
- Almost six.
- Oof, real veteran. Love you.
Hope everybody's doing well.
Thank you so much for
everybody who's listening
to the airport project.
Have you listened to the airport project?
- Yes, half of it.
- See?
Do you see how scared she got
because she knew I was about
to ask her a very detailed question.
- I got to the one after the parents one.
- Good, seven.
See ya!
Should be a good day, a lot going on.
Hope to see all of you later.
We got some stuff, busy day though.
("Heartbound" by Mitchell Bailey)
Life is good.
If you're good enough
it always pays off,
that's the biggest thing
everybody's confused about.
With patience.
The reason patience is the best strategy
is because the merit of
your skills will play out
in the long-term.
Will it work out?
I don't know how talented you are.
My intuition is you're hungry as fuck.
And so that already
To me it's patience, ambition, and talent.
So
you've got ambition
everybody's got ambition.
Well let me rephrase, a lot
of people have ambition.
A lot of people actually have talent
especially if they're
self-aware of their ambition
and talent, then they can really win.
But nobody has patience.
- Photo?
- Hell yeah.
("Heartbound" by Mitchell
Bailey continues)
What's up vlog
So I'm heading to a
client meeting right now.
Big one.
Seven figures yall
Successful meeting with a new client.
This is Marcus Krzastek
What's going on?
Airplane project still in the back.
How you doing?
- Man, never better man.
- That's good man, that makes me happy.
One thing with him that's
different is the youngsters
fuck with him on a respect
level that's different.
That's why I'm gonna win.
- Yeah
- It's not how cool or big I'm gonna be
17 million Instagram followers
in four years is gonna
be great, it'll be cool,
but it's not gonna make
people, like I'm not
gonna be able to move
America to all of a sudden,
by myself give a fuck
about whatever the fuck
I deploy that against.
The thing you have is the
tentacles as an entrepreneur
in business, man, within
people that are moving culture.
- Yeah
- It doesn't matter what
the Migos are doing,
it matters who the Migos look up to.
That's where skill comes in man.
But fuck man, Atlanta is culture
And I think you need to
be super thoughtful about
how much leverage that actually is
- Right
- I think you guys take it for granted
You know,
it just feels normal,
you're so in it it feels normal.
You take it for granted.
Like I just think it's
fucking really matters.
Like at a level that fucking confuses me
Meaning like just watching
it go from LA Reed
Just watching it my whole
life, like the leverage
is so real.
- We're continuing to grow
- The thing that fucks with
me the most is the difference
between 21 Savage, Russ,
the Migos, Danny Glover,
the Hollywood shit that's
happening in the fucking suburbs
Like there's so much really happening,
that's what I'm good at.
I'm good at people's attention.
That's why I invested in
Facebook and Twitter and Uber
before everybody else, I
knew it was gonna happen.
I really think you guys
can build some big ass
business.
- It was a pleasure man.
This your name?
- That's me my man.
- Alright I'm gonna lock you in.
I'm on you big dog.
- When I put up the five,
don't shake my fucking hand.
(dramatic music)
- Hey man, appreciate it
- Stay healthy.
Did you get my look in the
camera because he grabbed my hand
Do you know this meme?
Did you capture it.
- Yeah that was the same thing
that happened at foot action
- I think we got it
I think you got it.
It's gonna be a meme and a half.
I did the five, he put shook it
and I looked in the camera
which is gonna be amazing
- Do you mind?
- Signing it?
- Can you make it out to
my brother by any chance?
- 100%, what's his name?
- His name's Collin
- Collin
- He actually bought five copies
- That's amazing
- He's dying. He's like
can you put my name in and
I was like, I might be
able to do you one better.
- Awesome.
There's a lot of great reasons
to build a personal brand.
Both on like a human selfish
level and on a business level
But the way to build the
best, biggest personal brand
is to not monetize the audience
- Yeah
- One of the ways I figured
out how to do that was
to get book deals and speaking
engagements where I wasn't
monetizing the audience.
The key is a couple things.
First and foremost, for
everybody here, and this is like
giving advice that will
transcend for everybody
There's three ways humans communicate,
the written word, audio, and video.
You should do them all
If you can, afford to.
And if you cannot, my
big thing is to become
self-aware of how you best communicate
It would be a real mitzvah,
using a nice Jewish
word on Hannukah, if you could do video
because video can give you the other two
and the way you do that is the way I do it
it's video, as you guys know
if you listen to my podcast,
that becomes audio pretty
easily, and you can
literally hire an intern or
somebody to work for free
based on the successes
you've had to transcribe it
into written.
And now you're reaching people everywhere,
now you have a blog and a
medium and a Linkedin presence
now you have a Youtube and
a Facebook video presence,
now you have a podcast presence.
My part of this equation
to make you win, is to try
to get you not to monetize
them for as long as possible
if ever.
There's no difference between
six figures and eight figures
like what's the fuckin difference,
like I get, I'm practical, I understand,
but like what two extra bedrooms,
like what an extra trip,
like the caviar supplement.
(laughter)
Like what, right?
The reason to make more money
to close a vulnerability
and an insecurity.
The reason young men want to
make money is to get girls.
- You already have her
(laughter)
- And that's the point,
like you literally have no
like there's not a whole
lot, especially if you
give any fucks about legacy.
People say they want legacy, but they use
that as a disguise to make more money.
Tell your story in a fuckin minute.
And then you have to understand
why this is important,
because tomorrow Instagram
announces that videos are
now not capped to one minute
and we're all like oh.
Like everybody makes decisions
based on the rules of today
when these platforms
change their rules on an
everyday basis.
So first, figure it out.
It was a lot easier to
convert people with the word
wine than it was in 1997 super Tuscans.
Right?
It's, I get it, it's
easier for you to fully
articulate your whole god
damn thing in three minutes
and nineteen seconds.
Go challenge yourselves
for once because this
is all becoming very
like you guys have it.
Cool, alright, I gotta go.
(light pop music)